as the casualty count mounts in ukraine
as the chinese communist party begins
ratcheting up the aggression in taiwan
as the post-cold war world order seems
to be on the brink of collapse the biden
administration wants to make sure that
you don't get distracted from the real
threat
global warming
hopefully president putin would realize
that in the northern part of his country
they used to live on 66 percent of a
nation that was over frozen land
now it's thawing
and his infrastructure is at risk
and the people of russia at risk and so
i hope president putin will help us to
stay on track with respect to what we
need to do
for the climate
yes that'll stop putin the man currently
shelling civilians and killing children
in ukraine the world leader famous for
assassinating journalists and poisoning
his political opponents with nerve
agents the ex-kgb spy who openly brags
about his ambition to reassemble the
soviet union once known as the evil
empire that man is going to call off his
soldiers
out of fear of greta thundberg and the
sun monster so hopes john kerry and the
biden administration and the scariest
part of all
is that john kerry just might be the
most lucid tactician in the entire
administration hold up glad you like
that clip you got to ring the bell
please i would appreciate that you ring
the bell you'll get notifications you
should also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review if
you wouldn't mind we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]